quick PSA tomorrow October 4th everyone
in the US's phone is going to ring
really loudly at the same time 2 20 PM
eastern time just so you know so the
reason it's happening is because every
three years the government is required
to test their integrated public alert
warning system we haven't needed it in a
while but it's just in case there's some
massive emergency that the entire
country needs to know about at the same
time like a media or something they got
to keep that tested so at exactly 2 20
PM Eastern everyone's phone in the US
that is on and that has cell service is
going to start blaring and get a message
and it will say this is a test of the
national wireless emergency alert system
no action is needed this is also going
to play on TVs and radios that are on so
there's a pretty good chance it's going
to be pretty loud in the U.S tomorrow
pretty briefly but just so you know it's
just a test no need to panic you might
not have an alarm set on your phone for
2 20 PM eastern time but your phone is
going to ring anyway because